[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días en france 24 este es
un magacín informativo 100% dedicado al
continente africano mi nombre es liviana
valencia que damos una mirada en
profundidad a los hechos de actualidad
de la semana en la cura de la humanidad
nigeria vive semanas de manifestaciones
en contra de la violencia policial que
han escalado a pedir el fin de la
corrupción y la falta de liderazgo la
nación más poblada del continente
africano
varios estados de nigeria estar en bajo
toque de queda incluyendo lados
el candidato opositor a la presidencia
de guinea conakry si se le da leo díaz
lo llamó a sus seguidores a reclamar la
victoria tras los comicios
presidenciales cuyos resultados dan como
ganador al octogenario presidente alpha
condé que lleva 10 años al mando del
país
y cientos de migrantes africanos en
barcelona y otras ciudades de españa
lideran manifestaciones pidiendo la
regularización de su estatus migratorio
y el respeto por sus derechos y los de
otras poblaciones migrantes que son
vulnerados en el país iniciamos entonces
con la información en áfrica a 7 días
porque el presidente de nigeria
muhammadu buhari se reunió con los
líderes de seguridad nacional mientras
el país continúa en una ola de protestas
en contra de la violencia policial
las apuestas militares se ofrecieron a
ser desplegadas en el estado de lagos de
ser necesario para proteger los sitios
gubernamentales y los negocios allí rige
un toque de queda y esto después de
denuncias según las cuales el ejército
abrió fuego contra ciudadanos en
manifestaciones pacíficas en el x y
allows a que según amnistía
internacional dejaron al menos 12
personas muertas el ejército niega la
presencia de soldados durante los hechos
un día de conmoción después de una noche
de enfrentamientos los nigerianos están
sumergidos en un espiral de protestas
contra la violencia policial que
terminan en más derramamiento de sangre
soldados dispararon contra los
manifestantes hiriendo a varios de ellos
según reportes de testigos la ministra
estaba con mi hermano en el mitin de
ayer y luego los militares vinieron y de
la nada dispararon indiscriminadamente
mira mis piernas casi las piernas
málaga las protestas contra los abusos
policiales continuaron a pesar del toque
de queda impuesto en la ciudad de lagos
el gobierno asegura que no había tropas
en el lugar no obstante la ong amnistía
internacional asegura tener evidencias
de que las fuerzas de seguridad han
matado a varias personas el gobernador
local desestimó las acusaciones e
informó que al menos 30 personas
resultaron heridas el ejército ha
calificado la situación como noticias
falsas desde principios de octubre miles
de nigerianos han denunciado casos de
abusos policiales como acoso asesinatos
y torturas a manos de una unidad
especial desde entonces la brigada
pero las manifestaciones se han
transformado en un movimiento
antigubernamental he escuchado que
nigeria estará mejor pero hasta ahora
estamos sufriendo por eso queremos
luchar por nuestros derechos el
presidente del país amadou bujari pidió
calma y se comprometió a brindar
justicia unidades antidisturbios se han
desplegado en todo el país y emplea en
cañones de agua y gases lacrimógenos
para controlar la situación
justamente el gobernador del estado del
lago negó que hubiera víctimas fatales a
manos de las fuerzas de seguridad sin
embargo el mandatario local afirmó que
una persona murió en un hospital debido
a un trauma craneoencefálico contundente
y calificó el caso como un hecho aislado
que está en investigación
pero los suns queridos residentes de
lagos
mientras oramos por la pronta
recuperación de los heridos es touch
nos comportamos en el hecho de que no
hemos registrado ninguna víctima
contrariamente a lo que circula
masivamente en las redes sociales su
familia previamente hablamos con kinsley
bona docente nigeriano radicado en
colombia que nos dio su opinión sobre la
tensa situación que se vive en el país
más poblado del continente africano ya
hace dos semanas hay protestas en mi
país que considero protesta pacífica que
están llamando int
no estás en español significa escuadrón
especial en tiro fue creada en 1992 es
una rama especial de la policía que está
encargado de delitos asociado a robo y
armas de fuego
este escuadrón ya vienen haciendo
ejecuciones extrajudiciales torturas y
otros tipos de de actividades ilegales
hasta amnesia internacional bakunin un
informe este año diciendo que desde
enero de 2017 hasta mayo de este año
hubo 82 casos de tortura malos tratos y
ejecuciones judiciales esa protesta
arrancó con un vídeo grabando
ejecutando unos jóvenes y círculos en
redes sociales la gente salió a
protestar hasta los celebridades de mi
país salieron a protestar diciendo no
queremos más
el gobierno el 11 de octubre respondió a
esta protesta diciendo que hay que ya
prefirieron el sars pero crearon swartz
las protestantes se incluyen dijimos no
queremos ni sartenes wards queremos una
reforma de la policía que les paguen
bien que indemniza en las víctimas de
estos casos entonces esa protesta ha
sido por esto el gobierno respuesta
respondiendo sacando soldados a matar la
gente y eso ya trascendió un poquito a
hinchas nada dice en corrupción
o sea ya no queremos corrupción mal
liderazgo y los demás el candidato de la
oposición en la república de guinea se
lo da león djaló afirmó haber ganado las
elecciones presidenciales del 18 de
octubre ya lo es el principal rival del
presidente alpha condé quieren busca un
tercer mandato después de un cambio en
la constitución que provocó violentas
protestas el opositor no dio cifras y
dijo que los datos se basan en el
recuento de su partido y que no son
oficiales ya lo pidió a sus partidarios
que continúen con la lucha hasta lograr
la victoria
y también pidió las fuerzas de defensa y
de seguridad que muestren moderación
tras días de disturbios que han dejado
al menos diez muertos
lifesize y juntos ahora nos toca a todos
luchar para preservar defender nuestra
victoria y ustedes saben que está
amenazada por alpha condé que no tenía
electores pero que tenía un ejército de
estafadores ellos transformaron el
sufragio a favor de alpha condé no
debemos aceptarlo ustedes ya están
luchando heróicamente en conakry en el
interior del país a pesar de la brutal
represión a pesar de las detenciones
arbitrarias a pesar de las
intimidaciones la lucha heroica
inevitablemente saldrá victoriosa me
gustaría aprovechar esta oportunidad
para pedir a nuestros compatriotas
miembros de las fuerzas de defensa y
seguridad que muestren moderación que
recuerden que su misión es proteger a
los guineanos todos los guineanos
independientemente de su afiliación
política
cambiamos de información porque los
migrantes africanos en barcelona españa
siguen reclamando la regularización de
su situación migratoria recientemente
lideraron una nueva manifestación esto
dio a la crítica situación en la que
viven muchos de ellos que tienen sólo 45
días para encontrar una solución o de lo
contrario podrían ser desalojados del
centro de acogida donde se encuentran
muchos de ellos
con lemas cánticos y pancartas los
migrantes en su mayoría africanos
denuncian violaciones a sus derechos y
se manifiestan para pedir el fin de la
ley de extranjería que impide la
integración y el derecho al trabajo de
las minorías étnicas también denuncian
la falta de transparencia y la demora en
la asignación de las citas para
gestionar los trámites otro obstáculo a
la hora de obtener sus papeles y la
pregunta es quién da citas las mafias o
el gobierno dio pregunta
las mafias
sobre el tema hablamos con la periodista
y activista leticia nguema que le y esto
fue lo que nos dijo
cada vez son más las desigualdades que
sufren los extranjeros indocumentados en
españa sobre todo a la hora de
regularizar su situación
el colectivo afrodescendiente denuncia a
menudo episodios racistas y de abuso
institucional y también encuentran
dificultades para acceder a una vivienda
digna ya los servicios mínimos
sanitarios por lo que se organizan en
diferentes plataformas y asociaciones
para participar en las manifestaciones
de reivindicación de derechos junto a
otros ciudadanos racializados con la
misma problemática
túnez solía ser el quinto exportador de
fosfatos del mundo pero hoy el país se
ve obligado a importar formatos de
argelia para satisfacer sus necesidades
de fertilizantes y para los agricultores
y también cumplir con sus compromisos
para 2020 es un gran costo para la
industria y para la economía tunecina
que ya estaba en crisis pues los
fosfatos se representan cerca del 3% del
producto interno bruto del país
sentí la luz o este atún esto ha estado
parado durante 15 días en estas canteras
mineras los jóvenes bloquean el acceso
al sitio un evento ya recurrente pues el
gobierno y los mineros desempleados aún
no han llegado a un acuerdo y hikmeh
show
cada vez que viene un funcionario nos
piden que los dejemos trabajar que le
demos uno o dos meses para encontrar una
solución eso hicimos los dejamos
trabajar al final de dos meses nos
acusan de delitos por nuestras protestas
y sus promesas no se cumplieron
estos jóvenes dicen que fueron
agraviados durante el reclutamiento
oficial la empresa había contratado en
masa después de la revolución para
apaciguar la ira social hoy la empresa
está en problemas financieros y dice que
no puede crear nuevos puestos mientras
los jóvenes no tienen muchas otras
opciones en esta región la tasa de
desempleo aquí es del 26% puedo trabajar
en este negocio puedo ser un conductor
este camión allí mismo sé cómo operar no
puedo trabajar en cualquier cosa
en los centros de lavado de fosfatos la
situación es la misma el impacto
económico de ese bloqueo es tan grande
que las autoridades anunciaron que
tenían que importar 60 mil toneladas de
nitrato de amonio de argelia chris
cooley
dicen que van a comprar fosfato en
argelia pero el fosfato está aquí mismo
aquí está trabajemos y tomemos este
fosfato en túnez los empleados del
tunisian que nicole cooke que convierte
el fosfato en fertilizante también
expresan
porque su empresa corre el riesgo de
quebrar la importación de mis fotos no
resolverá los problemas de nuestra
empresa ayuda a corto plazo pero no
estamos en el gran para todas las áreas
del sector ni un correo electrónico tras
24 causa fosfatos compañía dijo que
espera que el nuevo gobierno que está en
el poder desde principios siempre paga
de esta una de sus prioridades
y finalizamos con música que nos llega
también desde nigeria con uno de los
artistas más reconocidos del país
se trata de false y su más reciente
videoclip titulado one troll ser allí él
relata las relaciones entre las clases
sociales y el accionar de las
autoridades
así es
[Música]
y méxico han lidiado con
japón
campos
pues con esta buena música finalizamos
este capítulo de áfrica siete días y los
invitamos a continuar con más nuestra
página web www puntos 30-24 puntocom nos
vemos más adelante con más información
que desde con nosotros estos france24
y cuánta agua